مسلسل من اضخم انتاجات رمضان السنه عمل
بميزانيه ضخمه وكميه نجوم هائله نحن
بنتكلم عن اكثر من 60 نجم ونجمه مصريين
وعرب المسلسل من اخراج المخرج الكبير خالد
يوسف وماخوذ من روايه للاديب الراحل يوسف
ادريس يعني العمل عامل صدى كبير من وقت
الاعلان عنه بيتكلم عن فتره الحمله
الفرنسيه على مصر واحداثه بتدور في فترتين
زمنيتين ومثل ما قلنا كميه النجوم في فعلا
مو طبيعيه ومنهم احمد فهمي احمد اللي
تعودنا عليه في الادوار الكوميديه هذه
المره بيطلع خارج اطارها وبيفاجئنا كلنا
وماخذ دور بطوله في سر الباتع في شخصيه
حامد اللي بيبحث عن لغز مقام السلطان حامد
اللي الناس كلها بتلجا له عشان تحقق
امنياتها وخلال رحله بحثوا عن اللغز
بيلاقي ورقه في حفره داخل المقام مكتوب
عليها باللغه الفرنسيه وبيصب كل جهده عشان
يعرف ايش اللي مكتوب في الورقه المسلسل من
اول حلقه بيوعد بالكثير ومشوق الجمهور انه
يتابعوا احداثه القادمه
انا بدور على حكايه السلطان
مدد يا حبيبي السلطان
ملك يا حامد دلوقتي انا بحبها كانها من
دمي
ايه قصه الحب الحلوه دي
وهينضم الينا النجم احمد فهمي اهلا فيك
معنا يا احمد كل عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
وانت طيبه ربنا يخليك كل سنه وانت طيبه
وانت طيب ان شاء الله ومبروك العمل صراحه
من اول حلقه حسينا انه احنا امام عمل ضخم
جدا صراحه اذا تحكي لنا انت من البدايه
بعد طول غياب ايش اللي رجعك بهذه العمل
انا كان بقى لي سنتين دي تالت سنه
وبعتذر في اخر لحظه لاني كنت عايز اخش
بحاجه قويه وحاجه مكتوبه كويس وحاجه مبزول
فيها مجهود من الاول وفعلا كنت بعمل مسلسل
تاني خالص في الاول وبعد كده لقيته استاذ
خالد كلمني وشركه الانتاج المتاح طبعا
فرحت لهم فقالوا لي احنا عايزين نعمل
مسلسل سر الباتع استاذ خالد يوسف فقلت لهم
انا ماضي مسلسل تاني قالوا لي بس اقعد
واتكلم مع استاذ فلما قعدت اتكلمت انا
عارف ان هي روايه يوسف ادريس فقعدت اتكلمت
معاه فلقيت ان هي فرصه يعني ما تتفوتش ومش
بتيجي
في العمر يعني كتير ان انت تعمل عمل
بالضخامه دي يبقى فيه ميزانيه كبيره اعتقد
هو الميزانيه الاكبر في رمضان
[موسيقى]
في كل الاجيال كبيره جدا
فما ترددتش بصراحه وفوق مع خالد يوسف هو
مخرج كبير
وعنده مدرسته الخاصه وطريقته الخاصه
فمترددتش بصراحه يعني طبعا المسلسل هذا
اصلا يعني عوده كمان هو قويه بالنسبه له
بس انا في شيء لفتني صراحه احمد كل
الفنانين لمن كل سنه يعني احنا بنعمل كل
رمضان بنشوف من قبل الفنانين وكل حاجه
كلهم دائما بيلبسوا بيصوروا بيصوروا لاخر
رمضان انت مخلص تصوير ايش المعجزه هذه ده
انا عايز اقول لك انا اصلا بره مصر انا في
باريس
يعني ايه معجزه كيف صار هذا الشيء دخلتوا
تصوير بدري في تنظيم ايش السر
مبدئيا اول حاجه بتتعمل لان معظم في غلطه
بنقع فيها كلنا ان انت بتطور مثلا بعشرين
حلقه او بخمس او بعشره وتكتب وانت على
الهوا فما تبقاش لاحق وبتكمل لحد اخر
رمضان خالد يوسف كان مصر ان الحق الواحد
وتلاتين حلقه احنا 31 يكونوا مكتوبين من
قبل ما نخش نصلي فعشان كده كان عامل جدول
مظبوط جدا وهو كان مصر من الاول ان احنا
مش هنخش رمضان احنا هنخلص كلنا قبل رمضان
فانا مخلص تقريبا بقى لي يعني خلصت قبل
رمضان بحوالي اسبوع 10 ايام
رغم صعوبه المسلسل المسلسل صعب جدا اتكلمي
على حققتين زمانيتين
ب 600 ممثل اساسي منهم 60
او اقصد 600 ممثل موجودين ما بين ادوار
اساسيه وثانويه و60 اساسيين الستين اساسين
انت بتتكلمي فيهم دول تقريبا كلهم نجوم
لا هي واحده من الاشياء اللي لافته طبعا
زوجتك النجمه هنا الزاهد طبعا تح يه كتبت
حطت لك بوست على انستقرام وكانت بتقول فيه
انه الله يوفقك على تعبك الشهور اللي فاتت
وكانت يعني
بتوجهلك طبعا التحيه وانه يعني اللي
بينفهم من البوست حقها كمان انه يحط كذا
بوست طبعا انه كان متعب التصوير
لا لا كان موت يعني عمليات بحريه المسلسل
ده من اصعب الحاجات اللي صورتها هو نفسه
خالد يوسف ما كانش بينام يعني كان بيطلع
من
الاوردر بتاع العصري اللي هو انا بشتغل
فيه بعدين بيطلع في اللي هو فيه احمد
السعدني ما اطلع المونتاج وبعدين السنتين
اللي فاتوا دول كلهم انا عملت ثلاث اعمال
لسه ما تعرضوش يمكن ده اول واحد سره
الباتا وفي بعد كده السفاح بعد رمضان دي
قصه حقيقيه برضو مسلسل
على شاهد ان شاء الله ان شاء الله وبعد
كده في فيلم مستر اكس برضو كان بقى لي
سنتين بحضر فيه
ان شاء الله
فكان الموضوع مجهد جدا يعني والتلاته
مختلفه تماما عن بعض لكن سر هو
هو المسلسل مش بس هو مسلسل
بيتكلم عن الهويه المصريه فقط لا هو
بيتكلم كمان على
في اجتماعيات كتير وفي حاجات كتير تانيه
فهو انت عارفه خالد يوسف ومخرج جماهيري
جدا وهو قادر يعمل في مسلسل واحد على
مستوى الكتابه فالتنفيذ كان صعب جدا لا
يعرف يلعب اللعبه اللي هو يكون فيه
المسلسل عمق بس نفس الوقت يكون برضو مسلسل
ناجح جماهيريا طيب بس واحده من الاشياء
كمان اللي يعني مختلفه في هذا العمل انه
الناس عاده متعوده عليك في الكوميديا اكثر
احنا شفناك الان بطريقه مختلفه تماما هل
نقدر نقول انه خلاص يعني انت بتودع
الكوميديا وشاقك خط جديد يعني
لا لا خالص هو اللي حصل في فيلم العارف
كان من سنه ونص او سنتين مع احمد عز ايوه
صحيح
والفيلم نجاح كبير الحمد لله وكان كان
بدايه ان انا اوسع قماشتي او ان انا اقدر
اعمل حاجات تانيه مختلفه فالحمد لله الدور
لقى يعني طابور كبير عند الناس والفيلم
نفسه ناجح نجاح كبير فبدا يجيلي ادوار من
النوعيه دي كتير سواء او السفاح بس انا
هرجع تاني ان شاء الله في في عيد الاضحى
في فيلم مستر اكس هو فيلم كوميدي لا
الفتره الجايه ان شاء الله هيكون فيها
تنويه كتير يعني
وفي شايله حضانه ناس في اول حلقه انه
بيظهر اخوك كمان كريم فهمي معك
بس يعني ترى اول شيء في البدايه لما انا
بدات اتفرج على المسلسل ان المسلسل لاحمد
فهد فجاه يطلع لي كريم فهمي فيعني حصل
شويه اتلخبطه يعني هذه كانت مقصوده عشان
الشبه
اه استاذ خالد
كان يعني دور الاب هو ضيف شرف هيظهر
الحلقه الاولى وهيموت استاذ خالد قال لي
انا عايز كريم يعمل الدور لو بيقدر يجي
لنا ضيف شرف يعني فكلمت كريم فوافق على
طول وجه عمل وكان حلو جدا بصراحه عشان
كمان الشبه فهي ماشيه حلو والدور صعب جدا
لانه
بتتكلم في مشهدين او تلاته عايز توصل منهم
كل حاجه وكلهم كان فيهم عاليه جدا وفيهم
لحظات حلوه فكريم عملوا حلو بصراحه على
سيره كريم احمد بما انه يعني انت موجود
يعني همم كمان خلينا نتكلم شويه عنه هو
الفتره الماضيه حقق نجاحك جدا كبير في
مسلسل ازمه منتصف العمر الكل كان بيتكلم
عنه بس في نفس الوقت المسلسل عمل الجدل
رهيب رهيب رهيب وكان فيه هجوم ومش عارفه
ايش الكلام ده كله تحس انه ان ظلم ولا تحس
انه لا هم رفعوا الدوز في المسلسل ولا كيف
تحس
بالعكس
المسلسل نجح نجاح كبير جدا بس حسيت انه
ظلم في الهجوم اللي صار عليه بالعكس
الهجوم ده بعتبره نجاح يعني انت في الاخر
ما فيش حاجه ناجحه ناجحه الا وهيبقى عليها
جدل كبير ما فيش حاجه ناجحه بتعدي كده
مرور الكرام يا اما بقى تكون بناجحه
بالجان والكلام ده
لا بالعكس الجدل اللي اتعمل عليه ده شايف
ان هو مؤشر لنجاحه وبادي الفيلم كمان اللي
كريم نازل به بعد كده انا لحبيبي نزل بعدي
على طول فيلم هو في عيد الحب 14/2
والفيلم لا نجاح كبير برده جدا يعني اول
ما نزل متصدر يعني لا هي يبدو السنه سندكم
ما شاء الله يا احمد انا لسه المشوار طويل
لسه 30 حلقه ولسه السفاح بعدين لسه مستر
اكس ان شاء الله ان شاء الله هي هنا كتبت
في بوست انه السنه ان شاء الله دي سنتك
ونحنا يعني متوقعين هذا الشيء لانه
البدايه يعني الان قويه في سر البعثه
الصراحه
الافعال الحلوه جدا
ان انا شفت المسلسل صراحه يعني يعني
المتوقع اللي جاي صراحه كلنا في انتظار
القادم يعني
كمان حابه اسالك على قصه التتر كان مختلف
احمد حسان عن يعني اللي متعودين عليه
يعني هل انتم تشاورتوا مع المخرج خالد
يوسف قبلها انه ما تظهر اساميكم في
البدايه او كيف تم الموضوع انا من الاول
يعني من الاول انا مضيت يمكن اول واحد في
المسلسل فمضيت وكان يعني كان كان في العقد
ان كل واحد هيبقى مكانه فين في التتر
وبعدين انت عندك نجوم كتير جدا وناس كتير
جدا انا مش بتكلم على مين الاول ومين
التاني انا بكلمك حتى بعد كده يعني في
الثالث والرابع والخامس والحاجات دي
هتلاقي فيه دوشه كتير لان كلهم نجوم
والله انا حتى لما جم سالوني قلت لهم انا
شايف ان يعني زي
[موسيقى]